so one of the things we hear in the
modern world we could say it really is a
modern phenomena is this idea that
there's somehow something weird about
rituals that you know you hear it in
that we want things to be informal we
want things to be natural and that
somehow rituals are artificial we have
this idea you know you everybody has
heard some Christian come up to them and
try to convert them and say something
like you know what I believe isn't a
religion what I believe it's a
relationship right I don't like religion
I want a I'm spiritual but not religious
I want a relationship with God or a
relationship with the universe but I but
this whole idea of ritual and and and
liturgy all of this is is somehow
inauthentic you could say and that
there's this kind of raw authenticity
that we can get to and so hopefully we
can look at that and I'm going to try to
show you guys that in fact yeah rituals
are inevitable
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world so before we start I just
want to tell you guys that this month I
have recorded the 3rd of the patron only
videos it is an interpretation of
Rumplestiltskin and and it's it's it's a
wonderful story it's actually one of the
stories I find that has that shows
really this the problem of the end of
something and how it turns into the
beginning it's related to credit to
borrowing all right so in terms of this
problem of ritual now one of the reasons
why people seem to think that is that
there really is a there really is this
idea of like a pure this idea of like
pure unadulterated relationship right
this idea of pure connection this notion
that you know you can be and that is
related to being informal until we get
this idea that somehow intimacy is
informal that that you know to be able
to to to walk around in your underwear
and your belly out that if you're if you
can do that with someone it means that
oh yeah that's real intimacy you know
it's like the more and for who you get
the more the more that that's that
that's intimacy but that's not that that
is that's a strange misunderstanding of
how human relationships work in fact
human interaction is inevitably
ritualistic and we need to understand
that way if you want a way to understand
it to simply try the opposite right try
to do the opposite of how usual human
relationships work and you'll notice
just how ritualized our behavior is you
know I've given the example before the
people that you know if you think that
that you are not constantly engaging in
ritual behavior try this right try just
staring at someone for like three
minutes non-stop and see what happens
you know that person would come
extremely uneasy right try try to you
know I don't try to if you're as you're
talking to someone
try top starting
to pick your nose let's say and see see
what happens as you're talking to them
with your finger up your nose right we
don't realize to what extent are our
interim human hair interactions are
coded and our ritualized you know when
you speak to someone you look at you
look at them in the eye but you don't
look at them in the eye for too long you
look at them in the eye then you kind of
look somewhere else you look at them in
the eye there's this rhythm of looking
there's also a rhythm of exchange you
know you you have to say something for a
little while and then stop and then let
the earth the other person speak and
there's a there's a there's a kind of
dancing that appears in our relationship
that rhythm you know is a ritualized
reality there are all kinds of other
rituals that we have we say hello we
shake people's hands we you know you
don't speak to someone if you're you
don't stand behind someone in order to
speak to them you stand in front of them
in order to speak with them and the
thing that's interesting is that I know
I can already hear some of the arguments
that people will have is to say
something like yeah of course yeah okay
we have these social standard these
social manners in which to interact but
they're natural like they're they're
they're based on reality right so if you
if you stand behind someone and you
speak to them then they won't hear you
as well they won't be able to see your
facial expression and so and that's why
we stand in front of people and you know
it's like it's normal to extend your
hand to someone shaking someone's hand
you know it's it's related to it a
gesture of goodwill it's showing that
you don't have something in your hand
like a knife or something that you could
hurt them with you know saying hello is
the same you know you put your hands out
you're showing that you're not there to
hurt them it's like all of these are
meaningful and they're related to to to
reality and so the answer is of course
that's true of course it's true that all
these many rituals the ritual of looking
the ritual of this this rhythm of speech
you know also the the the even the
question of space between people there's
that there's a certain different
cultures have different amount of space
that you're allowed to be in
depending on who you're with and
although it changes with cultures there
is a universal reality which is that
there are different spaces in which you
can be in relation to someone depending
on your level of familiarity with them
you know all of this is analogous to
sacred space to sacred rhythms in terms
of of chanting in terms of precession
all of these are the same and what's
funny especially for the argument saying
that these rituals are natural or that
they they're meaningful it's like well
so are the religious rituals right you
know in a church the actions that you
pose are related to the reality that
you're facing so everything we do in
church is not arbitrary it's not
arbitrary rituals the rituals are really
are exactly the same kind of rituals
that you have an interaction with your
your friend or with a stranger and so
when we're in church we do things like
bow we bow before God bow before
something which is higher than us and
what that is is acknowledging your
position regarding someone else but we
do that even then once ourselves right
we bow our head like men you know so you
see someone you bow your head what do
you think you're doing when you're doing
that you're saying I'm not putting
myself above you I'm recognizing I'm
bowing my head to you I'm recognizing
you as I'm kind of putting myself under
you to a certain extent but it ended up
being being if the other person does the
same it ends up saying like we're
together but in church we bow to God we
also vowed to the priest the priest bow
to us and then we do things like
kneeling all of these all of these
making yourself lower is in relationship
to something to elevate something higher
you know we we do things like we do the
sign of the Cross like if you're you're
bothered by the sign of the Cross but
you're not bothered by hello it's like
why does this why did the sign of the
Cross why is that strange that as you
are engaging in something sacred you
would make a gesture with your hand but
it's not strange that if you're engaging
with another person you're gonna get
your you're making a gesture with your
hand it's like there's nothing strange
about I
one of them they're just there they're
just manners and their natural manners
like that the sign of the Cross I mean I
can go in I don't want to go into the
symbolism of the sign of the Cross but
maybe I make a video about that the sign
of the Cross is completely coherent in
terms of centering yourself placing
yourself in relationship to to God but
also bringing gathering your gathering
your yourself let's say into your into
your heart we can go into that later but
it's the same for all the rituals and
you know like I've talked to you about
this before this idea of standing
together looking in the same direction
all looking at at at the altar all
looking to that sacred space at the same
time singing at the same time reciting
at the same time you know that's a very
powerful thing to say words with other
people at the same time what do you
think that does it's not arbitrary it's
a manner to bring ourselves together
into the same vision into the same into
the same line confessing things together
all of that is completely coherent and
then you know and then ultimately
communion itself the ritualized eating
is is a high perversion of all of us
sitting around the table eating from the
same food and all the you know that this
idea that if you're able to sit around a
table with your family and everybody
speaks in turn and everybody is
respectful of the other person and
everybody is also leaving food for the
others all of these are ritualized
behaviors that we totally understand and
you only know that that you can only
realize that it's ritualized behavior
when you have someone who does the
opposite if you have someone who comes
to your house and his arrogant and is
and is a jerk and sits at the table and
and just starts grabbing things putting
them on their plate you know starts
eating with their mouths open
you know it's talking while they're
eating and this end is and is being
arrogant is taking up all the room and
not letting other people speak you'll
realize just how ritualized you're a
proper dinner is and so communion where
we all come together to the same cup to
the same table and we eat and drink
together right in our desire to be
united in to cry
it's the same as the not the same it's
like I said it's it's a million times
more but it's the same structure as you
gathering around the table with your
family and eating together in a manner
in which to show your unity not to show
but to participate in your unity as a
family so it's very important and
another aspect which is important to
understand is clothing for example and
so one of the things that you hear you
know especially in certain kind of
non-denominational Christian context is
that none are like you know they would
never want their person in front to be
wearing a vestment to be wearing a you
know like Oh who does he think he is I
know he's trying to separate himself
from the others he's trying to wear this
thing that separates him knows the
pastor just dresses like everybody else
you know he wears a shirt and ripped
jeans and you know he's got his hair
kind of messy and sits on the side of
the stage and it's like do you think
that that's not a ritualized behavior do
you think that do do you think that
rebellion it doesn't have a pattern
rebellion has a pattern informality also
has a pattern even even as you move
towards the informal it's part of the
meta pattern just like that's why I keep
talking to you guys about monsters and
death and all of this it's all part of
the meta pattern and so if you if you if
you think that being informal isn't
doesn't have a structure it totally has
a structure you know because we
recognize someone who is acting informal
we recognize them right away
I keep joking about how it's like I can
recognize a punk from a mile away you
know and he's being a rebel but he's
following those rules he's following
that he's following the pattern of what
it means to be a rebel what it means to
be a punk and so to sit on the stage
with a ripped shirt and without with a
t-shirt and ripped jeans is also
ritualized behavior the question is what
is it patterning like what reality is it
patterning is it is it patterning
something which which is there it
depends why you're in church like are
you in church to worship God are you in
church to recognize that there's
something above you then we're all going
to gather together in reverence and in
honor of the thing which is above us in
order to you know
unify us is if that's what you're doing
then maybe wearing ripped jeans
tshirt and sitting on the side of the
stage and and having your hair all messy
maybe that is not symbolizing that maybe
the ritual you're engaging in is not the
right ritual you know but it's still a
ritual you can't avoid it and what like
I said if you are a pastor and you're
the center of attention and everybody's
looking at you what you do and what you
wear is going to be meaningful by the
very fact that you are the center of
attention
you cannot avoid it you cannot avoid
manifesting meaning if you are the
person towards which everybody is turned
now the question is what are what
meaning are you manifesting what ritual
are you participating in what you know
what pattern are you engaged with - if
you engage in a pattern which tries to
negate the reality of what you're doing
which is that everybody's there
everybody's there and everybody's
looking at you because you're in the
front you're the one who's supposed to
interpret the Bible or tell speak the
Word of God but you want to act in a
manner which denies that it's a it's a
it's a kind of schizophrenia it's a kind
of what it would the worst thing that
it's not always but the worst thing that
can happen is that you are actually
eliciting that in people like you are
going to be just like the rock star also
has everybody's attention but then their
behavior as everybody patterns their
behavior on the rock star is to to
elicit you know the let's say that the
lower side of our patterns we could call
them in felt the more libidinal the more
libidinal dancing the more libidinal
patterns rather than matter than a walls
rather than something which is which is
which is beautiful and elegant and you
know which manifests how the world can
fit together so anyways I'm really
hoping that that is a little hint at how
rituals are inevitable I hope you
enjoyed it and all right guys I will see
you again soon if you enjoy the symbolic
world content there's a lot of things
you can do to help us out why not
subscribe please do go ahead and share
this to all your friends
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com